[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la porte la
vie et je vois je te regarde je t'écoute
et je te prends dans mes bras site avec
mes sens et mon coeur que je tu
accueilles je sens avant de te demande
de te le demander comment tu vas dans la
maison je te reçois avec mes collègues
j'ai créé un espace où l'on se rencontre
ici et maintenant un refuge où tout se
crée à chaque rencontre
toi flavie tu es né au nigeria dans
l'état d'edo il ya deux frères et une
soeur
tu parles aide aux anglais et yoruba un
peu la langue de ton père ton père et
fermiers ils cultivent du manioc et des
patates douces de mervans sur les
marchés à l'école tu es bonne élève
tu veux être médecin la petite fille que
tu étais fait écho à la petite fille que
j'étais moi je suis né en france
mon père est médecin dans une banlieue
ouvrière son cabinet de consultation se
situe dans la maison nous habitons petit
je vois des gens parfois en sang
débarqué par le portail du jardin
je me demande ce qui leur est arrivé
pendant le dîner
mon père raconte des histoires de ces
vies qu'il soigne j'aimerais être une
petite souris enfermé dans un tiroir de
son bureau
la vie tu as maintenant 18 ans tué à
l'école lorsque ton père meurt il avait
emprunté de l'argent à une secte
peut-être pour payer les études de ses
enfants
la dette retombe sur toi bah oui tu es
l'aîné aujourd'hui flavie tu as 22 ans
et tu dois rembourser 35000 euros mois à
18 ans j'ai envie de faire des choses
qui m'intéressent et ce qui m'intéresse
ce sont les gens j'ai envie de savoir ce
qui se passe à l'intérieur d'eux j'ai
envie de faire des choses avec eux j'ai
envie de voyager alors j'ai étudié
l'anthropologie puis l'anthropologie
médicale cette science qui attaquons
prendre comme on les sociétés gèrent la
maladie comment les individus la vivent
quels en sont les représentations les
liens avec le cosmos
l'idéologie de l'époque et du lieu je
pars sur les îles de l'océan indien dans
la forêt équatoriale du congo belge en
uruguay
et puis plus de dix ans avec les indiens
mayas au guatemala et au mexique
je travaille dans des missions avec
médecins du monde ou le cnrs je passe du
temps auprès de chaque population
suffisamment de temps parce que j'ai
besoin de comprendre qui ils sont
donc cet événement coeur voilà ce que
m'ont appris les mayas il n'y a donc
rien à comprendre
juste à partager avec le coeur un espace
temps sans rien attendre pleinement
présente c'est quoi être présente
c'est me rencontrer avec le monde le
monde réel il est ce qu'il est je
l'accueille et je crée du lien avec les
autres c'est d'avoir le courage et la
racine latine de ce mot et coeur de
prendre le risque de devenir ce que je
suis et de déployer mehal
un jour je suis assise en face de flavie
le téléphone sonne
j'attends un appel je m'excuse auprès
d'elle je décroche une dame je ne
connais pas me dit ça y est j'en ai une
une quoi bein je ne sais pas comment
dire
l'aïe a grossi lance une prostituée lui
dis-je
oui me dit mon interlocutrice soulagé
quand je raccroche je dis [ __ ] je suis
l'amdi flavie avec son sourire
nous avons beaucoup ri j'ai oublié de
vous dire mon métier c'est d'accompagner
les personnes en situation de
prostitution
les femmes certaines sont exploitées
vous le savez les travestis et
transgenres les hommes
alors nous manquons totalement de
jugement face à nos présupposés mon
interlocutrice enfermé dans son regard
sur la prostitution dont elle sait bien
qu'il n'est pas particulièrement
valorisant n'arrive pas à nommer la
personne qu'elle a en face d'elle les
personnes qui se prostituent s'enferme
tel aussi dans ce regard elles ont du
mal à se voir autrement à s'imaginer
avoir des compétences
elle se pose elle-même l'étiquette de
prostituées ce que fait flavie quand
elle me dit je suis là en riant ensemble
nous avons défié la représentation de la
[ __ ] nous avons tous des étiquettes
nouveau ambitions dont deux avec des
étiquettes
ils ont levé nous fait peur peur de nous
dévoiler peur de découvrir ce qu'elle
cache peur d'avoir mal nous étiquette
nous rassure c'est l'identité sur notre
carte
le masque que nous portons pour
l'extérieur le rôle que nous jouons
mais est ce qu'elle nous parle de nous
elles sont la représentation de ce que
nous sommes
ma carte d'identité prend le pas
seulement de réellement territoire je
deviens étrange à moi même et à l'autre
je fonctionne sur deux niveaux à niveau
visible pour moi et pour l'autre un
autre niveau
invisible clan destin
flavie elle en a même pas de carte
d'identité
parce que je remplis des bilans pour les
statistiques je doive faire entrer
flavie dans des cases né en afrique
subsaharienne femmes 20 35 ans elle
disparaît dans l'anonymat de
l'évaluation jeu compagne des personnes
pas des prostituées
je les accompagne
mais pourquoi pour leur permettre de
penser ce qu'on a rendu invisible aux
autres est soi même pour se rappeler de
qui on a été pour retrouver des désirs
et des ressentis enfouis pour faire
émerger de la cohérence dans une
histoire chaotique
nietzsche a dit il faut encore avoir du
chaos en soi pour pouvoir enfanter d'une
étoile qui danse
alors je vais faire voler en éclats les
étiquettes
je vais les regarder différemment pour
qu'elle se regarde différemment pour
qu'elles portent un autre regard sur
leur situation de prostitution pour
qu'elle transforme leur vécu en
expériences leurs expériences en
compétences et qu'elle s'ouvre
sur les autres mondes possibles
accompagner pour moi est une histoire de
rencontre une histoire de désir et de
plaisir partagé
à chaque rencontre c'est au fil de nos
rencontres que chacun de nous chaque
jour construit son identité et cette
construction là se fait dans un lien
affectif c'est comme ça que je me suis
construite
c'est comme ça que nous sommes foutus
les êtres humains alors c'est comme ça
que j'accompagne
j'interroge mes certitudes je navigue
dans mes incertitudes je suis toujours
en mouvement je prends et j'accepte le
risque de toujours me transformer et de
me dévoiler
je n'observe pas flavie je la regarde
telle qu'elle se présente à moi ici et
maintenant je prends son histoire en
cours en plongeant avec le coeur dans
son monde d'aujourd'hui alors nos deux
identités vont se rencontrer là où elles
en sont ici et maintenant elles vont se
construire
jour après jour nous allons refaire
ensemble le chemin de savez quoi elle
s'est construite depuis tout petit
à chaque rencontre nos regards vont se
croiser nous allons nous nourrir l'une
l'autre en miroir nous allons découvrir
des choses inconnues sur nous sur
l'autre sur le monde
ce qu'elle me dit me transforme et je le
lui dis et elle elle se transforme et
tracer son propre chemin
même si elle n'est pas le reflet de mon
histoire son histoire résonne forcément
avec la mienne
nous allons créer une nouvelle histoire
notre histoire
si je mets une distance entre elle et
moi je ne raconte je ne rencontre pas
les personnes que j'accompagne pourtant
c'est ce qu'on nous enseigne maintenir
une certaine distance pour se protéger
de me protéger de quoi l'on le font les
personnes représentent un danger pour
moi je devrais avoir peur de me perdre
en l avec elle peur de changer
mais si je pense avant tout à me
protéger je ne pense avant tout cas moi
et que serait une rencontre dans
laquelle je ne vais pas moi ma blanche
propose à l'autre d'aller je prends soin
de moi tout en prenant soin de l'autre
c'est le cadre égalitaire de la
rencontre alors flavie comment vas tu
quoi de neuf depuis la dernière fois
aujourd'hui flavie continue de me
raconter sa vie depuis le jour où tout a
basculé
le détail de ces traversées dont le
désert
la mer méditerranée le vent a soufflé
fort pour elle tous les fils sont
emmêlés elle est perdue alors avec quel
jeu des mâles je tisse
je des mails je dise encore pour créer
un ensemble dans lequel elle retrouve sa
cohérence
je te reconnais flavie à la fois
semblables étrangères unique
nous sommes si humainement lié ma petite
flamme vibre à l'intérieur de moi elle
me crie que la diane était sur le point
de s'éteindre mais tu es là je reconnais
encourage alors de flamme à flamme je
t'ouvre mon coeur c'est toi qui me
permet de t'accompagner le temps a passé
et je n'ai pas oublié la leçon des
meilleurs je te rencontre ici et
maintenant avec mon coeur cette
rencontre de choeur à coeur ne peut se
faire que dans cet instant-là 7 immédiat
la qui seule permet une perception
exacte de la réalité
le cerveau du coeur qui avec ses
quarante mille neurones on le sait
maintenant envoient l'information à
notre cerveau nous nous offrant ce que
nous avons dans le coeur et recevant ce
qui est dans le coeur de l'autre un
cadeau réciproque
la transformation par la porosité des
coeurs
tu n'es pas seul je suis avec toi ce que
tu me dis comment tu me le dis
des silences résonne dans moi parfois
une larme surgissent puis nourrir fond
la balance tu ne peux pas tout me dire
je ne veux pas tout savoir je te crois
ce que tu me racontes tu le dis pour la
première fois à quelqu'un pour moi c'est
aussi la première fois ton histoire est
unique
je ne sais jamais ce qui va se passer
c'est l'inconnu tout se crée jour après
jour tout se transforme dans un
mouvement permanent jamais abouti comme
toi je ne sors jamais de chaque
rencontre
la même que lorsque j'y suis entré
si je devais ici à maintenant
accompagner des personnes dans d'autres
situations
je ne changerais rien je garderai ce
même regard au coeur de l'humain dans
lequel on ne parle plus d'un compagnon
et d'accompagner mais d'une danse des
identités flavie je ne te vois tellement
pas comme une [ __ ]
la france a reconnu victime de la traite
et a décidé de te protéger
maintenant tu as des papiers tu appris
le français
tu parle quatre langues j'ai repris des
études et tu travailles tu trace d'un
chemin dur est une étoile qui danse
[Applaudissements]